Here's an interesting voicemail I received
about the future for Andrew Yang.
Let's take a listen to it.
The phone number of course, 200 900 to David
P.
Hey David.
I just want to know what you think about Andrew
Yang's future.
Do you think he's just going to disappear
or do you think, um, in mind somehow get into,
try to aim for another seat?
Um, I believe, I believe he's just going to
disappear until the next election.
Next election.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I've gotten versions of this question from
a few people.
I don't think that Andrew Yang is angling
for, nor is he necessarily being looked at
by anybody for like a cabinet level position.
I just don't see it.
I think it would be very pop plausible or
probable that after the democratic primary,
which I don't believe Andrew Yang is going
to win.
I know there were followers of his in my audience
who say any second now he's going to take
the lead.
I just don't see that.
I think that he will do, I think he will go
back to the business world.
Maybe the interaction of business and politics
with the growth in name recognition that he
has garnered, uh, as a result of his run for
presidency.
I don't know that I see Andrew Yang even particularly
interested in just working only within the
political system if he's not going to be president
because I think it would be quite frankly
limiting for him as someone whose background
is as an entrepreneur.
Let me know what you think.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about an African American security
guard who was fired after asking a student
not to call him the N. that's crazy.
He is now back to work.
Uh, we will also talk about a push to have
cars not allowed drunk drivers to drive them.
Uh, this is a technological push that exists,
and we will talk about Mitt Romney secret
Twitter account, Pierre de electo, which is
just a hilarious, that's much better than
the fake names I use.
And I'll tell you about some of the, on the
bonus show, joined pacman.com to become a
member and get instant access to the bonus.
Check the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.